im august 2002 erschüttern zwei brutale
verbrechen die ganze schweiz in der
vergangenen nacht sind dann zwei orten
unweit von behren mitten auf der straße
zwei junge frauen niedergestochen worden
es passiert also getrost gab es passiert
die 20-jährige natalias lipsky wurde
brutal ermordet eine andere junge frau
schwer verletzt schnell wird klar
bei mörder muss es sich um einen
serientäter handeln bern ist in angst nach
21 tagen ist er gefasst die polizei hat er
schon lange vor dem mord nach ihm gefahndet
warum konnte man ihn nicht früher stoppen
eine bushaltestelle in bern bümpliz in der
nacht auf den ersten august 2002 astrid k
hat am späten abend in der stadt den bus nach
bümpliz genommen den rest des heimwegs liegt die
23 jährige zu fuß zurück der student die fällt
ein sportlicher radfahrer auf der mann ist er
unheimlich wenn sie fühlt sich verfolgt direkt
vor ihrer haustür fällt der unbekannte astrid k
an und verletzt sie mit sieben messerstichen
lebensgefährlich gelähmt bleibt sie liegen
in derselben nacht im vier kilometer entfernten
niederwangen ein weiteres verbrechen nur eine
stunde nach dem brutalen überfall auf a streetcar
findet ein securitas angestellte die leiche einer
jungen frau die 20 jährige maturandin natalias
lipsky wurde bestialisch ermordet oder christian
das muss ich gar nicht gut wie tot die frau des
staates bei 1 euro fällig und zweimal haben und
im moment nicht gut aus zwei grauenhafte
delikte eines in der stadt und eines auf
kantonsgebiet stadt und kantonspolizei bern
errichten eine gemeinsame einsatzzentrale
alle verfügbaren leute werden aufgeboten
erste erkenntnisse zeigen der täter war
der jungen frau vom bahnhof niederwangen
her durch die verlassene gegend gefolgt
sie hatte keine chance
es gab es passiert dass es nach der
tat entdeckt aber bei mir ist die
aktion in gedanken ich habe bemerkt
dass das passiert vater rolf zwahlen
hat die brutalen verbrechen kommen sehen
bereits ein halbes jahr zuvor wurden in
der umgebung von bern zwei junge frauen
brutal überfallen und schwer verletzt
kantonspolizist zwahlen hatte in diesen beiden
fällen ermittelt und schnell gemerkt es muss
einen zusammenhang geben zwischen seinen fällen
und einer reihe ungeklärter entreißt diebstähle in
der stadt bern im westen der stadt waren innerhalb
eines jahres zwei dutzend frauen überfallen worden
die polizei hatte damals die bewegungsmuster
des täters analysiert an der universität
zürich befassen sich experten mit geografischen
fahndungsmethoden strafrechtsprofessor christian
schwarzenegger kennt sich mit dem sogenannten
crime mapping aus damit kann man serientäter
geografisch eingrenzen heutzutage hat mir das
neues technisches mittel wo sehr hilfreich
ist zum bewegungsbilder und wohnort vertreter
zelebrieren wie geht das vor sich man hat als
geographische informationssystem das heißt matte
datenbank wo man die dort wohnen täter sie dort
früher tackern zeichnen um kann aufgrund
vergrössern wahrscheinlichkeit aus seiner
karriere wohnen ungefähr wohnt und mit welchem
verkehrsmittel er sich ungefähr zu denen tatort
hier bewegt hat er weiß zum beispiel dass
in 70 prozent vor der fahrt gedauert dann
amtlicher im umkreis von 30 kilometer vom
gleichen ort stattfindet und wie 40 prozent
sind sogar in umkreis von zehn kilometern
man weiß außerdem dass es ein gewisser ruf
geht zwischen dem wohnort von täter und über
den tatort das nutzt man um das sie gebiert
serie ihre wo immer wahrscheinlicher sind für den
wohnort und wo er wahrscheinlich sind für daten
so war auch die berner polizei vorgegangen
sie wusste alle delikte sowohl die and raise
diebstähle als auch die zwei tötungsversuche
waren in der nähe von tram bus oder s bahn
stationen passiert schon ein halbes jahr vor dem
grauenhaften mord hatte die polizei deshalb den
öffentlichen verkehr überwacht erfolglos das
phantom hacken-tor bewegt und musik sondern
genauso center woche fand er zwar ein trupp
bereits anfangs 2002 akribisch die spuren zusammen
und analysierte die tatorte er wusste der täter
war immer derselbe der mann wurde von tag zu tag
brutaler für zahlen war klar das phantom würde
auch vor mord nicht zurückschrecken was damals
niemand ahnt dieser waffen läufer ist das phantom
während die polizei fieberhaft nach ihm sucht lebt
er in bern ein unauffälliges leben und arbeitet
als koch im restaurant schlüssel michael hat eine
freundin und ist äußerst beliebt sein umfeld
beschreibt ihn als freundlich und hilfsbereit
niemand ahnt welche abgründe sich hinter dieser
fassade verbergen auch sehr liebenswürdig erlaubt
zum beispiel mir ging deshalb machten enttäuscht
sie kochen backen der mann ist wirklich gabi khz
schockieren aufsteiger einmal wenn fotos sie jetzt
hughes augen ist zwei mal auf dem hof frisiert
und das als jogger oder das detail sagte kaeser
danke vielmals wie shani verbringt einen großen
teil seiner freizeit bei der familie bürger im
berner oberland hier trainierte auch regelmäßig
für seine läufe die bechers hatten michael durch
den sport kennen gelernt genauso wie martin stoll
weniger er ist selbst langstrecken und waffen
läuferisch zielstrebig westlotto will und er
ist trotzdem unsere menschlichen umgang lag sie
ein loyaler gleichwohl kameradschaftlich serien
gute tipps und dem kolleg ja so verlassen so sieht
der ofin ist ganz klar sie also ich glaube nicht
dass er mich jemals irgendwo dura entscheid
für das macht für dich und es nicht gemacht
oder und damit recht macht also zuverlässig
es sicher sehr bzw als thomas steg natürlich
der sport wählten spitze sprachen meier witzig
sie denke ich mir schon als kleiner schock sie
der ehrgeiz zahlt sich aus mit erst 23 jahren
gewinnt michael im november 1998 zum ersten mal
den berühmten frauenfelder waffen laufen michael
steckt sich hohe sportliche ziele eines wird
er noch erreichen drei jahre nach seinem großen
triumph liegt er im november 2001 in frauenfeld
erneut dass er die fantasie als quälerei sexuell
zu missbrauchen dass er die fantasie schon an
dass er unter den fantasien liter hat und dass
er auf alle möglichen ort und wie es versucht
hat deine phantasie heizwert und der sport das
streusalz beherrsche ich für ihn offensichtlich
möglichkeit sie sondern ihr fantasiert verringern
gerichtspsychiater josef sachs ist leitender arzt
an der psychiatrischen klinik königsfelden er
hat den fall intensiv verfolgt den täter aber
nie begutachtet während michael noch erfolge
feiert hat die polizei schon einige spuren von
ihm zusammen getragen sie kann sie aber nicht
zuordnen deshalb bleibt er vorläufig unentdeckt
ein halbes jahr vor dem mord weiß die polizei
das phantom lauert seinen opfern stets in der
nähe öffentlicher verkehrsmittel auf sie
kennt auch die schrift des täters einigen
opfern und der polizei hat er anonyme briefe
geschrieben und die polizei kennt sogar seine
dna der täter hat an verschiedenen tatorten und
gegenständen speichel spuren hinterlassen die dort
in dresden teil die rote lag täglich mit der mol
amerikas prächtig so möglich gebaut und so hätten
eindeutig märz da diese art sind daten steigen da
zb zerstörte weiter länger dafür wird es für total
die steigerung kann man sich so erklären dass
das enormen suchtfaktor hält er hat eine sehr
schöne kleine renaissance das hätte man damit wenn
der diebstahl ohne nachdenken muss aber noch wie
viel es bedeutet schließlich die uci aber weil
es sich selber als derzeit nach sascha petrick
merkt dass das irgendwas bedürfnisse befriedigen
teil des ganzes versteckt mit dem vlies und wenn
es mit dem schlusspfiff riediger twitters
derartiges bedürfnis den ruf dass noch mehr
meppen ist fast als ob es passiert und das
männliche dem energieversorger fertigkeit
intensiviert problematischen taxi wir
haben das phantom gejagt und mit 240
van der zwaan muss hilflos zusehen wie
es zur katastrophe kommt natalias lipsky
wird brutal ermordet astrid k die der täter
eine stunde zuvor mit dem messer attackiert
hat überlebt ist aber gelebt sie hat den
täter als einzige gesehen in der klinik
wird sie deshalb rund um die uhr bewacht
sie will heute nicht mehr erkannt werden
auch die bevölkerung hat angst was vorher
nur die polizei wusste allen jetzt alle der
täter ist ein serientäter frauen getrauen sich
abends nicht mehr allein auf die straße in der
stadt bern sind die taxis über tage ausgebucht die
pfefferspray es in den apotheken sind ausverkauft
es hat natürlich dies ist auch im privatleben
auch andere die aber der schlüssel so viel
früher einführen bevor die vor der haustüre
stand auch bedenken dass ich eigentlich gange
alle haben angst und alle sind misstrauisch
jeder könnte der täter sein und er könnte
jederzeit wieder zuschlagen das weiß auch
die polizei sie steht in diesen tagen unter
enormen druck zeitweise sind mehr als
50 beamte im einsatz die zeit drängt
die polizei holt sich hilfe beim dinner
star kriminalpsychologen thomas müller
einen möglichen und wahrscheinlichen situationen
ist dass es hier zu einer art internen eskalation
beim täter gekommen ist da spricht einiges
dafür und eine der schlussfolgerungen die
wir daraus ziehen können ist dass dieser mann
schlussendlich jetzt ein gutes gespräch brachten
entwickelt im vorjahr weiter der täter will
kommunizieren schon am gleichen tag beginnt
er damit der polizei umschläge zuzuspielen in
den umschlägen sind persönliche gegenstände
der ermordeten natalias lipsky jeder brief
enthält zudem eine zettel mit ortsnamen in
bätterkinden oder burgdorf die fundorte sind
fünf verschiedene gemeinden nördlich von bern
somit komplettierte mit einem schieber sie mit
der foto-aktion museumsmacher der bestimmung
und probiere es auch leid sondern als lotte
mit trainer schaefer und musiker vorwärtsgang
erwarteten gebiet vorteil oder einfach diese
fortzusetzen mit dem gebiet der täter will die
fahnder von der stadt weg lockt doch die polizei
fällt nicht darauf rein stattdessen geht sie in
die offensive und veröffentlichte schriftproben
und zwei robot bilder medien und straff folglich
stellen die mir ambivalente verhältnis eines
gilt unschuldsvermutung dh die personen sollten
möglichst nicht exponiert werte will es könnte sie
dass sie gar nicht schuldig sind und das kann man
auch immer wieder gutmachen der andere sieht
medien dazu die öffentlichkeit zu informieren
falls gefahr bestand und auf der anderen seite
auch als fahndungsmittel gesetzt werden dass
man zum beispiel das fahndungsbild zeigt und
allenfalls sogar in dialog treten mit dem täter
wie das dauert einfach lieber passiert ist die
polizei will das phantom bei seiner eitelkeit
packen bewusst zeichnet sie den täter schlecht
rasiert und durch das statisch auf der relativ
älter reagiert auf sich selber und wenn es
nicht stimmt hätte entsprechend zur wehr
gesetzt und darum sind wir echt zum schluss
vor das mit einem roboter bild und natürlich
grundlage um sagen zu können dass man dort
wirklich liebt jeder die varta führer habe
mit dem ziel das land reagiere und der täter
reagiert sofort doch die polizei durch schau
die mit dem französischen will abermals eine
falsche fährte legen der täter beschwert sich
auch über die bartstoppeln und moniert das sei
nicht freundlich er rasiere sich jeden morgen
nicht nur der täter reagiert weil der telefon
hotline der polizei gehen in den folgenden tagen
mehr als 700 hinweise ein es melden sich auffällig
viele junge frauen sie geben an sie seien in den
letzten monaten von einem mann angesprochen
worden der der täterbeschreibung entspreche
während die polizei jedem hinweis nach geht
erholt sich astrid kam nur langsam bis zur tat
nach zwar ballett ihr großes hobby ob sie jemals
wieder tanzen kann ist zu jener zeit ungewiss
die fläche zentrum blätter sondern habe
mich da glauben heimat es gibt mit
ledersitzen sich weder als lecker
hauptstadt
die polizei fahndet fieberhaft ohne erfolg der
druck wird immer größer man hat zwar bereits seit
einem halben jahr das dna-profil des phantoms
aber noch immer keinen dazu gehörenden täter
schließlich mischt sich auch die politik in den
fall ein die zuständige berner regierungsrätin
überlegt laut obmann massen dna tests durchführen
soll der nationalrat stimmt in der folge über das
neue dna gesetz ab viele parlamentarier
fordern jetzt nicht nur schwerverbrecher
sondern auch kleinkriminelle sollen in einer
zentralen dna datenbank gespeichert werden
die meisten mitgliedstaaten kredite sache mit
dem entließ diebstahls letztlich zum 1 wenn man
das feuer hat die horden identifizieren das
kommt so der betreiber nicht zuletzt deshalb
entscheidet der rat auch bei kleineren delikten
wie diebstähle darf eine dna-probe angeordnet
werden das dna-profil gesetz ist seit 2005
in kraft die erste erfahrungen mit dem gesetz
zeigen dass das richtige entscheidung sie
ist das nicht zu stark ii zeigen es geht
andere länder wie deutschland zum beispiel
wo das vorher sehr stark auf sexualdelikte
geschenkt hat das hat aber dazu geführt dass
man praktisch gar keine hits hat will mehr
wächst dass das delikt spektrum viel breiter
ist dass ich aus der kriminologische forschung
bekannt dass kriminelle karrieren nicht
einfach kindheit auf immer im gleichen
deliktbereich ablaufen sondern das dass es mutige
problemverhalten ist dass das risikoverhalten ist
wo sich gegen sich selber aber eben anders
und insofern ist es also notwendig dass man
die liegt bereit laut allerdings aber so wie
es in der schweiz gelöst ist es sinnvoll dass
mandanten bagatellbereich oder übertragen zum
beispiel völlig ausschließt das ist verständlich
fünf tage nach der tat flüchten er ging um
aber sportarten wenn es wirklich schaffen
trat gefragt aber packte aber müssten
alle irgendwie beschäftigen und man aber
zum schlafen da hängt ja noch lustig mache der
räume des amtes man hat das herabsetzen würden
sich die viertelstunde mit seiner telefonierten
offiziell falls in den ferien neu gemacht im
schwarz war nach hause trainingswoche
und jetzt das absolut nicht mit xavi
von den über 700 hinweisen die bei der
polizei eingehen ist einer entscheidend
brief pro monat
auf diesen brief stehen name und adresse
des absenders sie führen direkt zum täter
auch die jugendfreunde von michael reagieren
das neueste die handschrift im blick sie und
ihre einer sofort erkennt und selbst mal vor
allem die fahrer noch einige charaktere und
auch eine merken wenn man ihm diskutierten modelle
machen aber sie steht noch ganz weit weg oder so
verhaftung die beiden gewaltverbrechen in
bern bümpliz uns niederwangen sind geklärt
die polizei hat gestern abend in spiegel bei
bern einen 27 jährigen schweizer verhaftet
noch am selben abend ist der mann ein erstes
mal befragt worden dabei hatte ausgesagt beide
taten den tötungsversuch in bayern bümpliz
und das tötungsdelikt in niederwangen vom
31 juli erster august 2002 begangen zu
haben ist klar schneller vorangegangen
die ich mich immer am telefon gesehen
also noch kein bescheid erst gar nicht ab
das telefon abkühle und ja panik kaya
denkt es ist irgendetwas passiert mit
der hand das ist die harmonie könnte will
ja so aus frage was ist passiert plötzlich
sieht mich stört das gefühl dass gehören das
ist generell stärker wird schnell läuft jahr
zurück unsere füße nachdem der täter gefasst
ist finden die medien schnell heraus wer der
mitternachts mörder ist es ist der 27
jährige waffen läufer mischer ebner
davor hatte einfach angst unsicherheit
und gefasst ich gesehen wenn man ihn
von jetzt aber im grund genommen die
nach gar nicht mehr über den dollar
sind vergangenheit die miss lake
city war zwar nach und nach in der
vergangenheit auseinandersetzen und
weil die wiener staatsoper und mich
zurück doch die medien wollen wissen wie
konnte aus dem netten jungen von nebenan
ein mörder werden alle suchen in der vergangenheit
michaela und sein um zwei jahre älterer bruder
alex wachsen im idyllischen tut will im kanton
thurgau auf gemeinsam besuchen sie hier die
primarschule der ältere bruder ist mischa
engste bezugsperson er nimmt sich im alter von
25 jahren das leben nur wenige wissen damals
dass in diesem jungen leben schon viel
schlimmes passiert ist im alter von vier
und sechs jahren wurden die beiden brüder
von ihrer mutter im kinderheim abgegeben
becker ließ die geschwister damals kinder
psychiatrisch abklären die abwehr in den
klar zeige dass die rennen eigentlich defiziten
im emotionalen bereich also dass sie eigentlich
kabinen die kufe ist zu erwachsenen sondern nur
gegenseitig als kreisstadt sie finden zum spanier
nach der mutter nach ein paar fragen darin sie
auf das angesprochen worden sind ist das für
sie völlig die relevanz und zusätzlich zeigt
dass er hunger hat nach zu erwähnen liegt noch
nach hier sind praktische ihrer wo nix los ist
nachträglich den nachwuchs des kinderzimmers oder
sie ist praktisch immer donnerstags um hätte
die familie nie als als familie wusste die
geschwister werden von adoptiveltern liebevoll
aufgenommen die familie erhält therapeutische
unterstützung die kinder entwickeln sich gut auch
in den augen der experten wir kriegen sind enorm
schnell eigentlich ihr entwicklungsdefizite
oscar ein die sind zum teil zwei oder drei
jahren zog sie im verhalten der innenraum kurze
zeiten die eu aufgefangen umwelttag selbst der
familie sie ist wohin ein bild machte mit den
sn die erwähnten mit der natur vertraut gemacht
hat und allem drum und da wo sie vor organe
content und ich bin natürlich erschütterung
gegeben autofokus kann bin dass da wirklich
zweitens glück kann die gut die familie zu
finden und eigentlich sollte das nach hoenigs
korrigieren war vorher nicht gut laufen ist der
kurs zu seine schwierige kindheit tk ulm erstmals
sieht michael schnitt der behandlung wird das mal
bietet ärzte darunter leidet und was das für ihn
sehr schwierig ausgesehen dagegen hat das kann
ich nicht gut das ist nicht so schlimm dass ich
ja dass ich die sich nicht für mich relativ nahe
liegend dass sie schwierigkeiten oder sie das ist
tragisch aber in der flieger fehlt dass das gerät
spielt und dass wir verlieren unser menschen
belasten wieso hat es hat mir sehr leid nicht
jeder mensch erlebt dadurch endlich verlief noch
relativ die ort und wie es zu gewalt darum muss
man davon ausgehen dass andere faktoren eine
rolle gespielt und andere faktoren dank wi
snackt die persönlichkeit dort und wie es mit der
mit einer belastungen umgangen ist während der 27
jährige mischa ebner in untersuchungshaft sitzt
fügt sich das bild für die polizei stück um stück
zusammen ebner der seit drei jahren eine freundin
hat suchte obsessiv den kontakt zu jungen frauen
ermittler dass sony hätte frau ist die frau
relativ unkompliziert direkt angesprochen und das
ist ein relativ neues vw und elisabeth obst mit
dem nützt weil die frauen nichts mit ihm zu tun
haben wollten habe er sich an ihnen gerecht das
gab ebner später in der einvernahme zu protokoll
minute hat weitere straftaten gestanden
der mutmaßliche täter das tötungsdelikt sie
niederwangen hat im verlauf der bisherigen
befragungen gestanden auf den gebieten der
stadt bern des kantons bern sowie in einem anderen
kanton weitere straftaten begangen zu haben mischa
ebner gesteht insgesamt 29 delikte darunter
mehrere raubüberfälle drei tötungsversuche
und einen mord sowie einen weiteren überfall fünf
tage nach dem mord an natalja slawski seine opfer
wählte er alle zufällig aus zuständig sie aber
sie ist geständnis ich nicht wirklich klein ist
sexy sondern sich mehr ins klein ist sie in sich
selber als opfer klug dem schluss vor gesellschaft
von der frau also wenn alle im umfeld vorher sich
die nötige mühe und aufmerksamkeit geschenkt die
und liebe geschenkt hat und nur all die andere
frau von rangee bereitet nämlich auch im liebe
geschenkt hätten den bestand hätte dann wäre das
nie sowie co und das ist immer im vordergrund
stand und da hat es aber über die eltern nicht
wirklich wählerinnen und wähler über das reden
was die anderen falsch gemacht herum dass
es machen dass ich so froh dass ich schon
sehr berührt worden frauen super umfeld kann
und gut die btk familie kam wohin genau hat
und er ist sehr positiv aufgenommen worden
man hätte michael jegliche chance gehe und
dass ich für dienst wenig sie alles ich würde
ihn zu wenig sie nichts war ein gut genug was
hätte verhindern können dass er zum brutalen
mörder wurde die daten hatte gesteckt werde es
ist der frust skoda stellt die daten steckt
werdet 6 vor der polizei ist aber auch was
im umfeld das heft erscheint und dass er den
mit großer wahrscheinlichkeit inzwischen aber
mit großer wahrscheinlichkeit auf könnte die
polizei war mischa ebene ein halbes jahr lang
auf den fersen sie ging jeder spur und jedem
hinweis nach trotz aller spuren konnte man
ihn nicht früher fassen das beschäftigt
den chef der spezial fahndung bis heute
das hat vielleicht mit noch mehr glück und
ruf habe eine weitere krise ist nicht gang
zu den spuren zugeordnet der 19 nachdem der
täter endlich in haft sitzt macht astrid k
schnell fortschritte 11 doktor bedeutung
sich zwölf deutsche rollstuhl abgab das
ist halt mal ganz tief und stockumer
klopfen klinische redliches ist eine
koordinierte sie aber auch andere laufen das
ist wahrscheinlich der wichtigste moment gesehen
oskar sie bittet zum tee zurück wort ja das
bin halt gemacht ist enorm wichtig robbie und
ja immer kofferset wieder zurück sind habt ihr
natürlich nicht chris cox überhaupt möglich ist
nach dann das ist offen lässt big sie aus
dem gefängnis schreibt ebner viele briefe
an bekannte und freunde er entschuldigt sich
versucht sich zu erklären länger brief frau
vor ihm der schlepper schrecklich finde
oder gar nicht wusste was passiert sich
gegen ein ganz schlechter tag wie das bayerische
urgestein mischoxid kennen was ich als großes
problem und das ist die große frage warum
hat das gemacht sehr schnell nicht wirklich
schlüssige antwort eine antwort wird man nie
finden im november 2002 nimmt sich michaela
in seiner zelle das leben ich finde sehr viel
aggressionen kein wunder vorher hat eine frau
in moskau und wo ist ein etwas nicht selten
ist im suizid das vorbild konzentrierter und
deine ist wahrscheinlich größten bilanzierung
dahinter machte bilanzierte das islate verdiene
ich ein paar monate nach dem selbstmord
wird die akte mischer ebner geschlossen
nach halo kwadrat
astrid car konnte das paraplegiker-zentrum sechs
monate nach der tat verlassen mit eisernem willen
hat sie sich ins leben zurückgekämpft sie
muss auch heute noch regelmäßig zur therapie
die physischen und psychischen wunden bleiben
aber astrid k hat gelernt mit ihnen zu leben